could pretend them like this how does he
sound I don't know it sounds more like
you're asking oh my god he sounds like
Gollum oh yeah we gotta be uh it's a guy
named Trevor on GTA v there's three
characters in the game and video game
yes they video game and he looks like
anything it's fun exactly like okay the
moustache amputated her diary liked it
as this perfect literally Wow I think
you gotta be glad great that I look like
a video game character is he
good-looking
[Music]
so after shooting battlefield rush I met
Steven OGG he hit me up and said he was
gonna be in LA for a week and wanted to
shoot something crazy and silly came up
with an idea with a guy who puts on the
most advanced pair of VR goggles and
this is transported into a world where a
tutorial AI Steven dog shows him around
[Music]
like okay what kind of short can we do
in one week wrote it in two days
crazy location scout in two days and
then shot the piece in Adana very fast
it's awesome yeah we're heading over to
hang out with Adrian Derek Sonny you
probably don't recognize those names but
you definitely know their work have you
seen the rush trailer most importantly
the division series
Adrian directed most of those episodes
day one downtown Los Angeles at the
ritz-carlton this is a very tricky place
to get in especially you don't live
there which we don't luckily one of our
friends doesn't let us borrow his place
for the day we came in there with way
too much equipment to be suffering I
think this is the first day Sonny met
Steven yeah in his underwear ten years
ago a wind energy video contest
submitted a video watched some of the
others I won that looked really good I
was like wow this is like really well
shot I think they won the actually the
competition next year comes along and a
John Woo film competition we all make a
video for that take all our fake mp5s
out and firecrackers and lo and behold
there's a video in this film competition
as well it also looks really really good
for a color grading I instantly
recognized that this was the same person
who beat me in that other competition I
had found a nemesis we're making these
videos we saw a YouTube channel I see a
video posted online the Giants left4dead
mashup video this cinematography I've
seen is color grading someone I realized
so the same guys who frickin wasted us
it's film competition
lo and behold that's when I first met
Adrian we've been hanging out for what
like years now and then like officially
like two years he's never came to our
place it's good to get out before flight
to serve food that leads us to today
after some filming's of screaming and
pissing off few neighbors for being too
loud we move outside into the downtown
streets the busiest intersection in
downtown with 30 minutes to film this
entire scene we needed to make sure that
we made the most of it and we surrounded
the Prowler with our friends vehicles
that way every take the continuity will
be exactly the same because of time we
use two cameras to get twice the amount
of footage being that it is illegal to
have a lead actor act and drive at the
same time we hired our friend whose
professional stunt driver for all the
driving shots since Steven couldn't
physically drive the car we got to shoot
on this giant green screen at our friend
studio called on the mark media Thank
You Jerome Abe Johnny guys that on the
mark media you guys are amazing there's
this tank explode yeah thank you for
take fire just before switching it so I
haven't actually seen the show yet all
right so it's I think we can start by
watching it and we can talk about what
the effects needs to be finished
oh you saw probably a bunch in there
they're not 100% okay we have two weeks
to do all of the rest of the effects
regardless of whether or not the effects
are done the effects are not done that
sucks the videos going up without him
sky name Calvin who did a bunch of work
for Mike Deva and the Trump and Hillary
marshals that he did and we also have
Kyle Natal to get this really cool Zelda
video last year where's that earlier
this year think they're willing to help
and I have to get the effects files to
them one lives in Germany one lives in
Canada I live in Los Angeles because we
had limited time we decided to
storyboard the entire movie almost frame
by frame in gta5
[Music]
and having a storyboard on set it saved
us so much time if we didn't have those
storyboards we wouldn't have completed
this shoot this is a passion project
people had their day job trying to push
a project across the finish line when
there isn't really a budget it's kind of
tough and that's where Sam and Nico
jumped in after watching the project
they said we love this we would love to
release it on our channel to you guys
watching thank you so much hope you guys
liked it too the crew Vincent Jean Alec
inky head Doug ray chase Josh if I'm
forgetting one I'm sorry but bait
although every single person who came
out came on their own dime and they've
really helped this project make it what
it is
October 10th which means we have two
weeks to finish this and that's
important because we can't push this
video back any further because there are
other uploads coming after that that are
scheduled
[Music]
I'm acting more as the effects
supervisor on this project we easier
kind of not I ended up spending more
time writing emails than I do working on
shots finally getting my lunch break at
6:00 p.m. I finished a few shots
rendered him out started stressing as
how much work we have left to do
I don't think we'll be able get this
time I won't say Calvin's doing some
great work over in Germany the issue is
that he's using hitfilm and I didn't
know this no you can do great effects
and hit them hit films a fantastic
program I highly recommend however I've
been sending him files from
after-effects with work already done on
them today is Monday evening the video
goes out a week from today we're aiming
to have all of the effects done by
Wednesday so that Adrienne can color
correct it color grade it get sound
design and music and all that stuff and
I look up at you Carmichael there's a
light you just had to be here to get
that on camera so we were driving around
downtown LA trying to find the location
that works like the perfect backdrop and
we came across Nichols Park Lake
[Music]
you
[Music]
paddleboats and we thought well that'd
be cool to have Sivan myself in a paddle
boat the paddle don't renter looked at
Steven and he said you know you sound
very familiar it's exactly like the
mustache amplitude I really like it as
it's perfect literally huh I think you
got a glass great that I look like a
video game character he's a good looking
go scary huh that's weird
this guy doesn't have a hair he has a
little hair I mean oh look there's these
pictures - okay I'm gonna finish
everything on this list except for the
green screen shots the math just wait
till tomorrow to tackle those
[Music]
I would say like you know having a
storyboard really helped if we had stuck
to it perfectly it would be completely
different so important to stay organized
having everything in its respective bins
so for instance if I remember while
working with Seth if there was a tape
that I like that maybe Stephen said
something this way that I really liked
and I asked him hey do you remember the
stake he would then be able to go into
the spins and find it so much quicker
which makes you that much more efficient
as an editor it's super crucial that you
stay organized in the post-production
process Halloween no Halloween see Seth
took it upon himself to take screenshots
of everything that needs the effects
that way we kind of have a visual every
time I walk by which is a nice helpful
reminder and unfortunately I think Ren
got most of them these ring a good job
but it's Friday and has like what seven
green screen or eight yep probably more
probably like ten green screen shots to
do
I wonder how Ren's doing right now
[Music]
oh that's what that light is asleep
we're supposed to have final effects
done last night these green screen shots
are taking a lot of effort I've got like
two of the 13 green screen shots done I
could slap all these shots together
pretty quickly but they won't look good
and that's the issue I refuse to do any
all-nighters or work the weekend on this
[Music]
this is a pretty cool spot oh and
there's my dog
we are coloring in DaVinci Resolve this
isn't really the normal look I would go
for I really want to incorporate really
wacky colors I use the color grading
after effect I kind of took all of my
experience from coloring and after
effects and then while learning DaVinci
I kind of just do the same thing guys
might be wondering why it's so dark up
here compared to downstairs color
grading it needs to be dark so there's a
consistent lighting setup it is very
important to have a controlled and
consistent lighting environment when
color grading when we get these shots
from Ren once he's done which I'm
assuming is going to be later at night
since he's still working hard on them I
can just drop your shots into the
timeline and then with the click of a
bud pretty much replicate the look that
I've created on say this specific shot
yes it does it has to come out Monday I
managed to stay fairly stress-free on
this project there wasn't any like
trying to get it all done and things
aren't working good that what happened
all like Mario skate was probably the
most stressful project I have worked on
in years
what made Mario Galaxy stressful is that
I'd never done something like that
before so there are a lot of unforeseen
challenges and this time it was just a
simple matter of there are so many
effects and on top of doing a lot of the
effects I'm having to coordinate with
other artists who are only doing some of
the effects in short amount of time this
is the end of the video and I really
hope you enjoyed it Carmichael there's a
pretty good job whatever I've got
another 48 hours so we got another one
drop it and then 48 hours after that
till the third one
[Music]
Shh